qué tal Santiago muy buenas noches
También felicitaciones a usted y a todo
el equipo de Francia 24 Pues sí fue
bastante informal el evento tuvo dos
horas de retraso esperando la llegada
del presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
quien estuvo con tres de suministros
algunos empresarios autoridades locales
estrecharon como usted lo decía las
manos de los funcionarios venezolanos
posteriormente hizo ciertos anuncios en
una que inicialmente iba a ser una rueda
de prensa Pero al final se convirtió en
una declaración de 12 minutos cientos de
personas aglomeradas de lado y lado de
la frontera celebrando por supuesto esta
normalización de las relaciones ahora
entonces la nueva operación será de la
siguiente manera paso peatonal entre
cinco de la mañana y 8 de la mañana que
viene siendo así Durante los últimos
años porque nunca se ha cerrado Este
paso peatonal y del vehículos de carga
entre las 10 de la mañana y las 6 de la
tarde Santiago Daniela justamente quiero
retomar algunas de las palabras que dijo
el presidente Petro allí presidente
colombiano que dijo hizo importantes
anuncios y pues su ausencia de su
contraparte venezolano Nicolás Maduro no
estuvo allí
claro no estuvo acá pero sí fue digamos
parte del discurso de Gustavo Petro
quien dijo que no se va a volver a
cerrar esta frontera que Nunca debió
haberse cerrado en lo que calificó como
un desastre humanitario y anunció que
abrirá el puente de tienditas Este es un
puente ubicado unos 20 kilómetros del
puente internacional Simón Bolívar que
servirá para el transporte de carga y el
transporte de pasajeros de todas maneras
acá la incertidumbre en esta zona
Santiago del país en Cúcuta que es la
zona fronteriza con Venezuela es cuando
se va a abrir ese paso de transporte de
transporte Pues de pasajeros el
transporte intermunicipal y también qué
va a pasar con las exportaciones Hoy
hubo cuatro camiones entre Colombia
Venezuela Colombia pero no se sabe bien
Cuáles van a ser las condiciones de esas
exportaciones Y eso está pues entre por
supuesto entre la mesa en las
negociaciones que va a haber entre
Colombia y Venezuela en los próximos
meses según anunció el presidente